frank kaminsky kind enough to join us
the Charlotte Hornets forward official
height and weight Frank is what 7 1 250
pounds how tall were you in eighth grade
6-1 6-1 yeah Wow
and then I had a growth spurt yeah
apparently the poll question would you
rather be 7 feet and no athleticism or 5
feet no athleticism and you weigh in on
which side 7 feet no question ok what
are the positives about when you're 5
feet tall that is such a disadvantage
with women it's unbelievable oh that's
my official stance ok so that's all this
is based on as being seven feet tall
helps you with the ladies more than
being 5 feet oh very well so I take me
into all over being short just for that
fact alone yeah but you still have to
deal with life as a 7-footer like wait
how are you how are you in a car you
you're comfortable in a car you can go
out and you know drive any car yeah yeah
I have a Jeep I love it I said fine
there's such a misconception that being
7 feet tall is such a disadvantage on so
many things like there's things that I
can't do like I can't go on
rollercoasters anymore but I don't care
cuz I never really liked rollercoasters
to begin with I need to extend it golf
clubs like there's things I have to do
because I'm 7 feet tall but it's but
it's awesome being this tall like it
would suck to be really short in my
opinion there has to be some net like
you run into doorways and light fixtures
things like that right yeah cuz I'm
really bad at texting and walking in
time so I tend to do this what are the
plans for the offseason um in Charlotte
between Charlie and Chicago just getting
workouts then got a couple weddings
it's about it maybe a trip to Europe I
don't know
who do you work out with I'm a bot I'm a
fly by the seat of your pants kind of
guy I like it
who are you working out with my workout
I got people in a Chicago I workout with
and then obviously we got a new staff
here in Charlotte so I've been getting
in down here and getting to know
everyone and working out with them it's
been great so far it's been a good
summer
last time Jordan came to practice was
when you know he's in and out throughout
practices as far as actually being
involved in practice you know he hasn't
really done that since I've been here
but he's always he'll sit in on a lot of
stuff and watch and give feedback and
stuff like that but as far as like
hands-on stuff inside of practices not
really so nobody's challenged Jordan
nobody said anything where Jordan then
goes all right let me put you in your
place that hasn't happened recently no I
don't think I don't think I would take
that chance really even you right now
against Jordan in a shooting contest I
mean I take that chance
I mean I think I can shoot the ball
really well and all of that but you
don't wanna I don't know it's a weird
looming presence that kind of makes you
a little bit uncomfortable sometimes
that you don't want to challenge the
greatest basketball player of all time I
feel like his competitive nature would
almost make it a little bit too much to
to unfun yeah but I would want the
challenge of just saying I tried it I'd
rather that he roughed me up and stared
me down and made me get into a fetal
position but still you you know you took
on the goat right I mean you could
always say you won but I mean I don't
know hey is Kemba Walker gonna get
traded no idea I don't I don't know
what's gonna happen I hope not he's like
my favorite teammate I've ever played
basketball with so I want to be I want
to have him on my team or be on his team
for a very
a long time okay since he's your best
buddy does he think he's gonna get
traded um no I don't think so he's been
in Charlotte for a long time now he's a
two-time all-star I think he's really
built his life here his whole family's
here he loves being here so I don't
think he's gonna I don't think he thinks
he's going to get traded but you have to
realize at the end of the day that the
NBA still is a business and anything can
happen yeah um so I guess we'll see how
it all plays out
what about how surprised were you Dwight
Howard got built it was a little
surprising you know obviously with the
new staff and everybody obviously a lot
of new people in the front office there
isn't much knowing what the true plan is
obviously they came in with a plan and
they're executing it now so you don't
really know what's going to happen or
what their true plan is but I mean
they're asking for feedback and looking
for people to just be here and be
working hard and stuff like that and
obviously you know there's there's
pieces that they see fit for their new
system and pieces that they don't see
fit for their new system and I don't
know if I don't know if Dwight was a
piece that was going to fit the way that
they want to play going forward well he
doesn't fit now with today's NBA whereas
15 years ago you had to have a Dwight
Howard now it's your seven footers got
to be like you you got to be able to
play it at least on the perimeter right
yeah but there's different styles
obviously there's still there's still a
market place in the NBA for guys that
can averaged a double-double every
single game and he's a guy that can do
that so you know obviously he's an
extreme talent and can do so many things
he's so physically gifted that he's able
to do so many things on our basketball
floor so like I said it's all system and
how you see the players on your team
fitting that system going forward Franks
thanks for joining us on no pun intended
short notice here and weighing in on our
poll question have fun this summer and
we'll check in with you soon thank you
it's Frank Kaminsky a proud 7-footer for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]